we're going to begin this hour with
Oprah she is here she is revealing her
newest book club selection only on CBS
mornings and we love when that happens
Oprah drum roll please what did you
select oh it is the long-awaited
Covenant of Water by Abraham berghis
and it is big it is it is 715 Pages yes
but I felt transported I felt like I
lived in a different land for a while I
felt expanded I came away humbled that
someone could have a Mastery of words
the way Dr varghese does and I am just I
think this is an offering to the world I
I just I know that it's a big thick book
and you were complaining about that no
no and this is what would happen well
I'm going to wait till we introduce the
author the Covenant of what follows the
Covenant of water a South Indian family
suffering from a very mysterious curse
during the search for answers family
secrets are revealed that Bond them
together but also threaten to tear them
apart Abraham bergees last New York
Times best-selling cutting for stone
sold more than one and a half million
copies in this country alone so we are
very excited to have you here Abraham
berghis and we welcome you yes when I
heard that the book was 700 pages said
Oprah people have lives this is not fair
to do to people people have jobs they
have children they have work and so when
I was reading it I would call her and I
say it's so long she goes is it good I
go it's beyond good she said well keep
reading and hung up the phone she's not
hearing she said and she said I make no
apologies for the lens so my challenge
here today is not to give anything away
because it's Pitch Perfect it takes
twists and turns that you never ever
expect grabs you right from the
beginning right from the beginning all
the way to the very last page so what
was your process how did you come up
with this story well I wish I could say
that I knew the whole story from the
beginning but uh I had a general idea
three generations I had the figure of
bigamichi a strong woman I think a lot
of women in fiction are portrayed as
evil or you know malevolent but I just
wanted a good mother and have her sort
of carry the story I knew very little
else I mapped it all out but it kept
changing every time as you were writing
so were you changing as you went along
it was I think there's a saying and
fiction that character is determined by
decisions taken under pressure and the
moment I put my character Under Pressure
they would tell me they were going a
different ways this is what I loved
about the book I thought this expressed
on page 15 very beginning of the the
story the grandmother is certain of a
few things a tale that leaves its
imprint on a listener tells the truth
about how the world lives and so
unavoidably it is about families their
victories and wounds and their departed
including the ghosts who linger it must
offer instructions for living in God's
realm where Joy never spares one from
Sorrows it up beautifully too that is
sentence plus yes that is sweep that is
Grandeur uh Dr varghese you are a doctor
and a writer how do these two
professions these two callings interact
you know I always resist the the
Temptation the the definition of two
hats because I see myself it's just all
physician and even the writing comes out
of the great privilege of
in physicianhood and being attentive to
details and trying to gather them
together in one unifying package I mean
I realize that's a bit disingenuous now
I have a best-selling book that I've
written before this and I'm on Oprah
yeah I must be a writer but uh yes my
identity is so wrapped up in in the
great privilege of being a physician you
know what was touching to me is your eye
drop you and Oprah met for the first
time today your eyes teared up when you
were speaking to her what was it like
when she called you I'm wondering where
where the emotion came from for you
about her well I gave her some grief I
think because I didn't believe this this
was two days before April 1st so I
didn't really believe this was Oprah but
once I knew I stood up that was my first
reaction you stood up I stood up I'm in
awe of this lady who you know who
brought so many readers to books in
general and that's what writers want I
shared with her one of my favorite
quotes that the difference between
people who don't read and who can't read
is no difference
and she brought readers this is Mark
Twain's quote not mine yeah she brought
readers to books and I just loved this
lady for that he cheered up and I
cheered up we both were crying in the
call that's never happened to him ever
because I just feel like what it takes
to have a day job and then really you're
doing this for in your spare time
writing but to have the gift of being
able to use words to put people in a
different place in their mind and in
their their spirit is an incredible gift
seeing this connection in this
conversation between you two is
beautiful and this isn't going to stop
here there's some exciting news about it
exciting news because tell us all about
it this is the first time I've taken a
fiction book and turned it into a series
of podcasts because the story is epic it
has brought in scope and I know that uh
already Dr varghese has so many fans out
there from cutting for stone which I
hadn't read until I read this book then
I went and read cutting so so many fans
who want to delve in a more intimate way
with the story and so we're doing it a
super a series of podcasts series on the
books on the book not only that Dr Ray
gaze Abraham this is the first time I've
ever seen Oprah pick a book from an
author and then go back and read all of
their other books I've never seen you do
it's never happened before I mean her
enthusiasm when she called me for the
book yes just going on about it other
than my editor and my publisher and my
partner no one has ever read the book in
that and being that engaged I was just
blown away I mean I got to my knees when
we were done with the call now Dr
Ricky's you mentioned earlier that you
mapped it out and you mean that
literally you mapped it out on a
whiteboard three generations of families
um kind of explain your writing process
for us is that your whiteboard there I
tend to think visually and so wow I
really wanted to have a blueprint before
I
before I launched into this but the
trouble is as I said the blueprint kept
changing and so there are many many
iterations of my whiteboard so it kept
catching up with the novel I wish I
could say I knew it all but that was my
attempt did you know how this was going
to end when you started it I I wondered
about that because the ending I think is
is Pitch Perfect did you did you in the
back of your mind towards the end and
I'll tell you something else I had the
privilege of recording the audiobook and
as I was reading it for two and a half
weeks I was seeing connections I swear
to God I never planned to put in there
so I think the Muse God the subconscious
mind does mysterious things and you just
have to be open to it and willing no I
like what you say about secrets you say
every family has Secrets but not all
secrets are meant to deceive what
defines a family is not blood but the
secrets they share I think that
resonates with many many many yes I
would like to say I've been reading
since I was three years old and I have
over the year you know I I what what's
the prize in my house or my book my my
first edition novels and I have a whole
room full of them and I would say this
is this goes on my list of top three
books of all times wow and that includes
wow Miss Tony Morrison all right so I
have never felt this way about a book
I'm I'm trying to get the rights of the
book I want to I said I said to to
Abraham for geese I don't know whether
they call you doctor or Abraham Abraham
okay I said to Abraham that you know I
believe that this should be a series a
multipart multi-part series I have never
you know attempted in all of my years of
selecting books to do a series wow after
I showed up but I said I want to be the
steward of this however this comes to
light on the screen and whatever screen
it is I feel that I should be the
steward for this to make sure that this
story gets what it deserves in the world
you feel that when you start yes yes and
it's it's it's one of the top three
books Abraham what was waiting for you
after more than 10 years of work with
that white board and having the story
pass through how does it feel here
it's just an awesome feeling I mean you
know I think you're right in such
Solitude and you're but you're always
visualizing a listener and I never in my
wildest dreams imagined Mr military
would be be a listener something tells
me a Oprah knows people so this is going
to happen I think in her mind she's
already casting for the book yeah that's
the movie aren't you you got something I
got some people in mind all right I
think Oprah and Abraham thank you thank
you it's a pleasure pleasure to meet you
guys you know what we're doing so
normally I would choose another book
around July we're giving people time to
read this book because I I listen this
is going to take you on an adventure
it's going to take you into another way
of being with yourself and so we're I
won't be back here for a while so people
get two months to read two months I
think that's very important because
Oprah people got lives
thank you both thank you both the
Covenant of water is on sale right now
check out cbsmornings.com for reader's
guide and a free excerpt from the novel
just ahead head on over to our Instagram
page to find out how you can get more
involved with Oprah's Book Club all
right